(upbeat jazz music)
- [Linda] Unless you're from New Orleans,
you would not know nothing
about the Hangover Hotline.
- [Male] I feel like my
head is going to explode.
Can I please have some of your soup?
- Yes, I got that hangover cure.
I'm on my way.
(upbeat jazz music)
My name is Chef Linda Green.
I am called the Ya-Ka-Mein Lady.
Ya-ka-mein is one of New
Orleans' best kept secret.
It's a noodle soup.
Ya-ka-mein was classified
as a poor-man dish.
It is Chinese and
African-American fusion.
It's good for the soul.
It's good for a hangover. (laughs)
Oh my God, when it hits the tongue,
it goes to the brain,
and then it come back to the tongue,
and say, "I want more."
My mother was a cafeteria technician.
I was a cafeteria technician, too.
My mom and my grandmother
used to cook ya-ka-mein
and she always did tell me that
I may be able one day to use it,
and she was right.
When Katrina hit,
everyone lost their jobs.
I needed a job after I lost
my job with the school.
I was catering, and I
was selling ya-ka-mein
at a lot of the festivals in the city.
I won Gumbo Festival.
I won Sushi Festival.
I've been winning a lot.
Now I've just been very
persistent and consistent
with this ya-ka-mein, and it became popular;
and the phone was ringing off the hook.
Everybody used to say, "Where
the Ya-Ka-Mein Lady at?"
That's how I got that name.
You know, people from
all over were calling me.
There's a hotline there.
I deliver or some will
come and pick it up.
I went out on faith, and
I never looked back.
(upbeat jazz music)
I love my city, y'all.
I'm not going to tell y'all a word of lie.
I love my city.
My name got known because a hangover
is very common in New Orleans.
Ya-ka-mein is the best remedy
for a New Orleans-sized headache.
Everyone call it Old Sober.
I just love what I do.
I love cooking.
I love for someone to enjoy
my food, and I love for them
to come to me and tell me
everything was beautiful.